il est en ce moment sous le soleil de
rio pour un tournoi
le 6e déjà cette année félix auger alias
ims et la coqueluche du tennis montréal
et de ces dernières années 18 ans
seulement et un immense talent formé au
centre de tennis canada au stade iga
il est depuis cette année résident
fiscal de monaco monte carlo un paradis
fiscal qui n'impose pas les revenus de
ses
jacques roy ben mais c'est aussi un
paradis pour les joueurs de tennis
évidemment on l'encouragé pas ce que
savait le tennis se joue beaucoup à
l'europe par exemple à partir de havre
et des mois d'avril mai juin juillet
tous les tournois seront en europe
donc c'est l avantage de pouvoir entre
les tournois si on a perdu relativement
tôt dans un tournoi aller se ressourcer
chez soi si l'on relit seulement les
points entre les 29 tournois joués par
félix auger alias simon 2018
on totalise 70 mille kilomètres avec une
grande majorité de déplacements en
europe
impossible de nier que monaco permet de
l'optimisation fiscale
mais les joueurs payent des impôts là où
il gagne des matches à wimbledon par
exemple il laisse à l'état 50 % de leurs
gains 15 % de ce qu'il gagne en france
ou encore 30% à l'us open
tout comme chez nous quant à l'argent
investi pour former les joueurs
tennis canada reste convaincu qu'il y à
un retour sur investissement nous on a
un sens d'entraînement mais à partir
d'un certain niveau et ses niveaux de
fénis ça manque un petit peu pour félix
deux partenaires d'entraînement
et puis au niveau du retour sur l'a6
sport il jouera il représentera le
canada à longueur d'année et félix auger
alias hymne est du genre à redonner ses
gains pour sa participation à la coupe
davis
à l'automne dernier il les a reversé aux
joueuses canadiennes de moins de 14 ans
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal